enfin nous sommes le mardi 29 septembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal tout
de suite le résumé de votre actualité
locale ont commencé siècle la cosmetic
valley connaissez-vous la cosmetic
valley c'est un pôle de compétitivité
nationale spécialisée dans la filière
des parfums et des cosmétiques en france
à vélizy lutte est rattaché à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et labellisé justement par
la cosmetic valley il a fêté ce matin
les cinq ans de sa licence
professionnelle ventes et
commercialisation des produits
cosmétiques et parfumerie retour à
l'antenne de rambouillet où ce cursus
offre de nombreuses opportunités
d'emplois dans un secteur en pleine
croissance un reportage de fanny bourdon
vcp cpc le nom de la nouvelle licence
professionnelle de l'iut de vélizy
créé il ya cinq ans cette formation de
vente et commercialisation des produits
cosmétiques a formé à ce jour plus d'une
centaine d'étudiants un cursus en
alternance qui est en adéquation avec le
marché de l'emploi
j'ai cherché dans la formation c'est que
les jeunes en formation par alternance
accède à un travail à un métier et un
travail et
j'ai regardé autour de rambouillet quels
étaient les secteurs d'activités dans
lesquels on pourrait développer une
formation qui atteignent cet objectif et
c'est là que j'ai découvert l'existence
de la cosmetic valley et qu'il y avait
un pôle très très important de
l'entreprise de cosmétiques
sachant que le luxe et la cosmétique
c'est un des fleurons de l'économie
française c'est un des rares secteurs
qui fonctionne alors en national et
international me suis dit il ya une
symbiose entre notre position
géographique de formation et ces gens
qui sont autour de nous accessible à bac
+ 2 et pour une durée d'un an cette
licence professionnelle à les techniques
de vente et gestion commerciale
elle est labellisée par la cosmetic
valley un pôle de compétitivité qui
emploie plus de 70000 personnes en
france
la cosmetic valley c'est un pôle de
compétitivité c'est à dire que sur trois
régions normandie centre et ile de
france
ce pôle rassemble plus de 800
entreprises qui travaillent avec les
universités et les laboratoires de
recherche pour créer de l'emploi
consolider l'emploi le cosmétique est le
deuxième secteur qui contribue le plus à
l'export en france plus d'un cosmétique
sur 10 vendus dans le monde a été
produit sur notre territoire
de quoi affirmer le succès de cette
licence professionnelle qui offre de
nombreux débouchés
rappelez-vous le revers curiosity c'est
poser sur mars en août 2012 si la
mission pilotée par la nasa est
américaine des ingénieurs et chercheurs
français ils sont appliqués une dizaine
travail au latmos le laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales située à 80 ou coup à
guyancourt
ils sont à l'origine d'un des sous un
instrument de l'expérience sam simpl
analysé satmar ce qui analyse notamment
la composition de l'atmosphère
la mission s'est à nouveau parler d'elle
avec l' annonce de la nasa de la
présence d'eau liquide salée à la
surface de la planète rouge
on écoute si les opales chercheur au
latmos est responsable de sa main
malheureusement notre instrument samedi
il n'est pas n'est pas vraiment
directement concernés par ces
découvertes mais en tout cas la
découverte du sel permet à l'eau de
rester liquide ou de devenir l'hymne
assure fait demain qui s'appelle le
perchlorate dont on a beaucoup parlé
hier pendant la conférence de brefs
et bien femme ça a été le seul
instrument finalement de curiosity qui
permet la détection de ce terreau
chlorate et en fait on l'a mis en
évidence lors de premières analyses et
nous sommes aujourd'hui en plateau avec
diane maraval vous êtes je le rappelle
la responsable des petits frères des
pauvres des yvelines sur secteur
yvelines alors les petits frères des
pauvres c'est une association qui agit
depuis près de soixante dix ans auprès
des personnes âgées fragiles isolées en
situation de prouver pauvreté
d'exclusion ou de maladies graves
la journée internationale des personnes
âgées c'est le jeudi 1er octobre donc
dans deux jours il ya beaucoup
d'événements organisés sur les yvelines
et en france tout à fait dans toute la
france et notamment sur les yvelines
puisque c'est ce qui nous intéresse dans
les yvelines
comme dans toute la france on organise
qui s'appelle les fleurs de la
fraternité c'est une une grande
opération de sensibilisation sur la
thématique de la l'isolément des
personnes âgées avec l'idée que toutes
les générations et toutes les personnes
que l'on rencontre sont en capacité de
rentrer en contact avec des personnes
âgées isolées et pour cela on va dans la
rue devant les gars devant les magasins
dans des endroits publics des marchés
pour leur offrir une fleur et leur
demander de l'amener à une personne âgée
avec l'idée que c'est une excuse à la
rencontre en fait puisqu'on a une fleur
à les offrir
et que ça permet de créer du lien c'est
vraiment cette c'est l'occasion
justement de parler des personnes âgées
c'est un souci qui est peut-être moins
pris en compte par la société les gens à
denis porte fenêtre - alors ça dépend
des points de vue on peut se dire qu'il
ya énormément de personnes isolées une
étude de la fondation de france en 2014
point tel qu'il est à plus d'un million
et demi de personnes âgées isolées en
france donc ça veut dire que c'est une
question extrêmement prégnante pour
autant une étude encore plus récentes
ont montré que la plupart des français
se disent prêts à donner de leur temps
pour aller auprès des personnes âgées
donc on peut espérer que finalement
cette problématique est en train de
revenir sur le devant de la scène et
c'est cela que mon travail
alors il y aller l'événement des fleurs
de la fraternité cette opération cas
notamment à versailles il ya des points
de distribution pour regarder ça sur un
site internet
et il ya aussi des événements comme à
plaisir notamment une journée co
organisé avec l'hôpital
tout à fait on a des partenaires locaux
donc toutes les villes les cinq villes
sur lesquels on est
sur les yvelines vont faire cette
opération n'est présent à versailles a
plaisir à mantes la jolie saint germain
en laye et sartrouville à plaisir
puisque c'est ce dont vous me parlez
notre partenaire local s'est notamment
l' hôpital gérontologique de plaisir
grignon les bénévoles organisent donc
chaque année une un moment festif avec
les personnes âgées notamment d'un des
services de l'hôpital pour en faire un
moment de partage avec les personnes
âgées et une classe de sciences médico
sociales locales donc des jeunes ça
permet de faire un moment
intergénérationnel
puis ces jeunes et ces bénévoles vont
dans tout l'hôpital offrir les fleurs
aux personnes âgées vous essayer
justement d'impliquer plus les jeunes
avec vous dans l'association
alors on a une grande diversité dans le
bénévolat on a vraiment un bénévolat
traître est répartie en termes de
tranches d'âge donc on a à peu près un
tiers de jeunes un tiers de personnes
entre 30 et 45 ans et puis un tiers de
personnes un peu plus âgés et on essaye
effectivement de favoriser aujourd'hui
de plus en plus l'intergénérationnel it
et parce qu'on se rend compte que ces
riches pour toutes les générations pour
la première fois vous allez lancer une
campagne de pub avec des acteurs donc
avec marion game et philippe bertin ils
sont mises en scène la dent justement un
clip vidéo ils s'expriment sur leur
situation de personnes âgées donc il
joue un peu le rôle d'acteur il ya un
monologue où ils expliquent ce qu'ils
vivent au quotidien c'est vraiment une
nouveauté parce que c'est la première
fois que vous faites ça également
on essaie effectivement de faire appel à
des personnalités qui vont pouvoir
sensibiliser le grand public sur cette
question de l'isolément des personnes
âgées donc c'est ce à quoi se sont
prêtés ces deux acteurs et pour nous
c'est voilà c'est une bonne manière
d'atteindre un nouveau public
pour sensibiliser sur cette question le
fait justement de prendre des acteurs
c'est pour parer à cette situation mais
qui est quand même difficile à entendre
je pense peut-être de faire passer
messages pré plus doucement peut-être
plus doucement et puis à travers des
personnes comme une certaine popularité
donc qui ont aussi une audience en tout
cas à laquelle nous espérons faire
passer un message c'est compliqué là
justement il ya pas mal de deux
problématiques notamment avec des
migrants de recevront mobiliser les gens
sur les personnes âgées jeu je pense
qu'on a une bonne mobilisation d'un
quand même dix mille personnes en france
qui régulièrement à savoir quasiment
toutes les semaines vont rendre visite à
une personne âgée donc ça veut dire que
le bénévolat il est présent et pour une
vraie un vrai engagement une vraie
régularité
après c'est vrai que notre pôle de
bénévoles est en permanence en
renouvellement parce que pour des
questions de moments dans la vie
les personnes restent parfois un an
parfois disant parfois vingt ans mais on
est en permanence en recherche de
bénévoles pour renforcer nos équipes
parce que les besoins disais tout à
l'heure sont très présents si un million
et demi de personnes âgées sont isolés
en france ça veut dire qu'on a encore
beaucoup de travail
justement diane marage besoin de réagir
à ce petit micro-trottoir nous avons
demandé aux saint quentinois leur avis
sur la façon dont on devait aider les
personnes âgées
regardez il faut aller les voir chez eux
déjà au revoir comment il vont battre un
budget pour qu'on puisse avoir des gens
compétents qui peuvent aider ces gens là
n'ont étrangers dont par exemple aller
les voir leur rendre visite et cheval
leur donner un peu de joie et tous les
et des besoins des activités avec eux en
se rendant utile en étant jeunes ont
créé des associations par exemple pour
pouvoir faire des rencontres faire des
centres de lecture peut-être des
rencontres aussi dans les écoles
maternelles je crois que le lien
personnes âgées et enfants c'est quelque
chose qui qui fonctionne il disait vrai
justement alors assez saint quentinois
radial maraval moi je pense que c'est le
bon sens qui parle et que effectivement
c'est exactement le type de mission que
l'association s'efforce de mettre en
place à savoir des visites des
rencontres des moments où finalement les
personnes peuvent recréer du lien et
puis se recréer un réseau syndical et
relationnel et c'est ce à quoi
travaillent tous les bénévoles de
l'association effective alors justement
comment fait-on pour devenir bénévole
sont les petits frères des pauvres alors
je pense que le plus simple c'est de se
mettre de se rendre sur le site internet
de l'association donc www pour un petit
frère des pauvres point fr petit frère
au pluriel afin de voir justement quelle
est l'équipe la plus proche de son
domicile et de pouvoir prendre contact
pour les rencontrer que chacun puisse
voir si finalement les actions de
l'association correspondent à l'horreur
et la recette est concrètement qu'est-ce
que voilà les bénévoles sont amenés à
faire alors que font les bénévoles
effectivement c'est une piste importante
ils sont amenés à l'or il ya il ya un
panel très large de mission possible
la majorité des personnes qui viennent
vers nous viennent pour rendre visite à
des personnes âgées ça peut être
admissible ça peut être à l'hôpital ça
peut être dans des maisons de retraite
après on a aussi besoin de bénévoles
pour tout type d'action ça peut être
pour faire des conduites pour des
personnes sur des sorties ça peut être
pour nous aider administrativement
recherche des personnes pour nous aider
peut-être pour faire des comptes rendus
d d
des mises à trésors ville à
l'administratif exactement donc on a on
a un panel très large de bénévoles donc
l'idée c'est de se tourner vers l'équipe
la plus proche de son domicile pour voir
finalement quels sont les besoins et il
y aura toujours quelque chose à faire
pour nous aider
merci beaucoup diène larrazet l'est
devenu en plateau avec mais d'avoir
répondu à notre question je le rappelle
la journée internationale des personnes
âgées c'est le jeudi 1er octobre mais ce
n'est pas à vous renseigner sur un site
internet des petits frères des pauvres
dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi à
guyancourt a les jardins familiaux de la
rue du moulin renard ont été cambriolés
g3 motoculteurs ont été dérobés et une
cinquantaine de cabanons ont été visités
c'est la troisième fois en un an que des
vols sont constatés sur le sur ce site
heures regardez ce reportage de william
el est patrick jacques de dixmude voilà
ils sont restés là
chasser toute la serrure vraiment ils
ont écarté avec des appareils comme ça
sur les poteaux dominique en a plus
qu'assez en deux ans c'est la troisième
fois que les jardins familiaux de
guyancourt sous cambriolé l'année
dernière dix mille euros de matériel
avait été dérobée et encore 13 milles en
mai 2014
alors ça c'est du matériel qu'ils ont
que les voleurs ont dû décharger pour
pouvoir charger matériel s'est envolé
donc ils ont laissé le le matériel
qu'ils avaient dans leur camion un
canapé des héros d'un motoculteur ont
été volés dans un cabanon partager et
sur les 60 chalets 49 ont été visités
après que le cadenas et été fracturée
une perte estimée à plusieurs milliers
d'euros
ils ont pris déjà du matériel comme 1,3
motoculteurs pour la somme environ 2000
plus de 2000 euros et plus encore 5,6
motoculteur
d'autres jardiniers avec du matériel
aussi des débroussailleurs des groupes
électrogènes
enfin différents matériels comme ça et
quelques outils des caisses à outils des
visseuses le commissariat de trappes
chargé de l'enquète a déjà placé trois
suspects en garde à vue il pourrait
faire partie d'un réseau beaucoup plus
important pour l'instant l'enquêté suit
son cours et nous continuons avec de la
politique c'est le nouveau visage des
jeunes à républicain des yvelines for
and flora sa vague pardon et des primes
15 à 9 ans la responsable du mouvement
la jeune femme de 21 ans est étudiante
en droit et en sciences politiques à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
elle est également conseillère
municipale dans le groupe majoritaire à
feucherolles la jeune femme succède à
marie astrid de montmarin qui occupait
cette fonction depuis 2010 engagée très
tôt fera sa bague a été militante puis
responsable du mouvement étudiant de
droite uni dans les civils elle nous a
parlé de ses nouvelles responsabilités
écouter la passation s'est faite il y a
une dizaine de jours nous en avions
parlé un peu cet été mais ça s'est fait
vraiment dans l'apaisement dans le souci
doit rassembler est vraiment d'impulser
une dynamique au niveau des jeunes sur
le département
je m'inscris effectivement dans la
continuité tout en essayant
effectivement d'apporter cette dynamique
dont nous avons besoin pour les
élections régionales
recruter des militants c'est important
les former aussi intellectuellement les
formes effet provoquer du débat parce
que nos jeunes ne demandent pas que du
militantisme
ils demandent aussi à se confronter
intellectuellement et nous continuons en
politique un accord pour développer les
logements en milieu rural a été signé
aujourd'hui à l'hôtel du département de
versailles ce protocole concerne plus de
150 villages y viennois avec une
population de moins de 2000 habitants
parmi les communes concernées on
retrouve bailly toussus-le-noble rennes
moulin tient malgré lyon ou encore les
essarts le roi pour soutenir le
programme le département a décidé de
développer une enveloppe de 2,2 millions
d'euros
objectif construire 220 logements
sociaux entre 2016 et 2018 une nécessité
pour le département des yvelines selon
alain schmidt l'un des responsables du
projet les fautes au micro dé michael et
demi d'euros ont dérivé pourquoi vouloir
construire en centre-ville a gelé les
logements sociaux et bien tout
simplement pour des raisons d'abord une
partie de la population qui est une
partie de la population âgée qui se
retrouvant seul dans des maisons les ans
étant parti souhaite rester dans les
villages qui souvent les ont vu naître
mais en coeur de bourg et onu ne
souhaite qu occupe évidemment qu'un
appartement or on ne trouve pas
d'appartement au coeur de village donc
nécessité pour cela de construire et
puis également un apport de population
plus jeune
ce qui est intéressant puisque ça permet
de maintenir en activité les écoles
maternelles les écoles primaires donc
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait de
tout à fait fondamentale et une page de
sport à présent c'était le derby à ne
pas manquer ce week-end trappe rencontré
versailles un match attendu dans le
cadre de la coupe de france les
supporters trappistes étaient survoltés
ils ont mis l'ambiance je propose de
regarder ce sujet de mickaël miro
scénario cruel pour trappe au 4e tour de
la coupe de france les saint quentinois
qui évolue en promotion d'honneur ont
failli réaliser l'exploit en éliminant
versa une équipe de dh trois divisions
au-dessus des trappistes les joueurs de
mo china ou s'ils ont réussi à arracher
le nul 2 partout pour pousser les
versailles jusqu'en prolongation
l'histoire était trop belle trappe s'est
finalement incliné aux tirs au but 4
tirs au but à 3 on passe pas loin on
frôle l'exploit
on peut avoir quelques regrets on a deux
fois l'occasion de d'aggraver le score
bonnes notes en main une balle de 3
ensuite on à l'expulsion derrière qui
nous fait un peu mal on se retrouve à
dix on tient le coup mais bon après
voilà on n'a pas à rougir de notre
prestation on a fait un bon match ce qui
a fait la différence et des petits
détails on a vu l'écart entre la ph la
dh et aujourd'hui on va travailler pour
notre objectif la fin d'année on arriva
à sortir du traquenard trappe
un match où on retiendra la
qualification tout simplement place au
championnat maintenant pour trappe
l'équipe est pour l'instant en tête de
la poule c de promotion d'honneur avec
deux victoires en deux matches les
trappistes compte surfer sur cette
rencontre en coupe de france pour
continuer à rêver de la montée nous faut
qu'on se concentre sur le championnat
c'est vraiment notre objectif
prioritaire la coupe de france bat on la
joue et on a eu un beau public
aujourd'hui et on va essayer de le
continuer pour que ce soit le cas pour
tout le championnat
ce que je retiens c'est cette positif au
niveau de l'état d'esprit on a montré
qu'on était une belle équipe avec des
valeurs et c'est encourageant pour la
suite
prochain match pour trappe dimanche
prochain contre malakoff à l'extérieur
objectif réussir la passe de trois en
championnat et avant de fermer cette
édition un mot sur les élections
régionales le medef la chambre de
commerce de paris et la cgpme ile de
france ont décidé de s'unir pour
interpeller les candidats de tous les
partis à la présidence de la région ile
de france
ils ont ainsi organisé ce mardi 29
septembre une conférence débat au siège
du medef où tous les candidats sont
conviés sur place william el est fanny
bourdillon écouter bonsoir florane c'est
une première au niveau de la région
parisienne les antennes régionales du
medef de la chambre de commerce et de la
cgpme ont décidé de s'unir pour
interpeller les candidats de tous les
partis à la présidence de la région ce
soir une conférence débat entre les
représentants des entreprises
d'ile-de-france et les candidats des
différents partis
ce soir seront présents les candidats ps
emmanuelle cosse pour les verts valérie
pécresse pour les républicains mais
aussi leurs homologues des autres partis
fn debout la france lutte ouvrière et
front de gauche je me trouve avec agnès
l'eau jacomo présidente du medef
ile-de-france année cela giacomo bonsoir
un cahier de doléances a été écrit par
les entreprises franciliennes
il va être remis ce soir aux différents
représentants des partis quels sont les
grands axes de ce cahier de doléances
alors avant de vous répondre je voudrais
quand même dire que c'est une première
au niveau de la région ile de france
mais c'est également une première au
niveau des autres régions à notre
connaissance c'est la première fois que
l'ensemble des organisations patronales
ont fait un front uni pour pause pour
poser aux candidats les questions
concernant les prochaines élections
régionales
alors nous avons rédigé un document un
document qui est issu du terrain qui a
été fait avec tous les représentants sur
le terrain de nos entreprises et qui
aborde les grands thèmes de la région
vous savez que la région a des
responsabilités très importante en
matière de transport en matière de
développement économiques en matière de
logement mais également vous savez que
les entreprises sont les premiers
financeurs de la région ile de france et
donc c'est à ce titre que nous posons à
tous les têtes de liste de ces
différents élections régionales les
questions qui tiennent le plus à coeur
au chef d'entreprise vous disais
justement les transports avec le
développement du grand paris mais aussi
le développement du réseau de transport
ça va être un enjeu dans ces élections
pour les enrobés
c'est un très grand enjeu dans les
élections c'est aussi un enjeu pour
avoir des seins en jeu pour remporter
les grands challenge auquel nous nous
sommes engagés c'est à dire les jeux
olympiques de 2024 et l'exposition
universelle de 2025 vous savez que sans
ce réseau grand paris express nous
n'avons aucune chance de les avoir
donc à terme ce sera très bon pour le
développement économique et pendant
toute cette phase ce sera également très
bon pour toutes les entreprises de
travaux publics et bâtiments qui vont
avoir à travailler pendant plus de dix
ans sur ce chantier dans l'est également
de rapprocher le monde de la recherche
de celui des entreprises
c'est très important quand on regarde
dans les housses avec l'innovation c'est
quelque chose qui est fondamental pour
favoriser le développement économique
quand on regarde en france nous avons
des chercheurs en matières fondamentales
qui sont très présents
vous croyez qu'on entend les chercheurs
fondamentaux qui sont très présents avec
d'excellentes qualités dès qu'il s'agit
de faire de la recherche appliquée nous
sommes moins bons que certains pays
anglo saxons et nous pensons
véritablement que c'est dû au fait que
les chercheurs sont la recherche est
trop éloignée de l'entreprise eh bien
merci agnès l'eau jacomo donc la
conférence débat devrait commencer dans
quelques instants c'est ce soir qu'on
devrait voir se dessiner les premiers
grands axes des différents partis en
faveur des entreprises et nous
reviendrons sur ce débat avec les
candidats à la région ile de france dans
notre édition de demain je veux demain
je vais me rendez vous demain à 17h en
direct vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée